in today's video we're going to be
learning from a youtube expert with over
546 million views on his main channel
and we're actually going to be talking
about five advanced youtube strategies
that really nobody's talking about so
maybe if you watch a lot of different
youtube tips videos online i recommend
you stick around until the end of this
video because we're going to be getting
into some nuanced strategies that are
going to help you get more views get
more subscribers and ultimately make a
greater impact with your content all
that and more is coming up today on the
growth video live show
[Music]
welcome back to the growth video live
show my name is sean cannell rhymes with
youtube channel and i am so fired up
today to be welcoming evan carmichael to
the show by the way check out time codes
and chapters uh if you want to skip
around in this video but evan good to
see you how you doing dude sean cannell
rhymes with youtube channel i haven't
heard that one before
i mean people say canel
so i actually was like you know it
worked out because it kind of helps with
the branding but it actually is truly
the rhythmic
you know channel i like it dude i like
it that's great i love it hey great to
be here awesome i mean uh i love
everything you're doing it's been
amazing watching your journey grow and
even just the events from just doing
your own kind of solo team events to now
what what your events have become it's
just
it's it's awesome dude it's awesome
seeing the ogs
how they're growing and still getting
better and still having a hustle and
still rising and grinding you're an
inspiration dude
well i appreciate that so much and we're
gonna get straight into these tips but
if people are just meeting you break
down your story in a nutshell your
channel now has over three million
subscribers you actually have multiple
channels um where did you come from and
how did you get here
uh well i think ultimately your purpose
comes from your pain so i think whatever
you struggled the most with is what you
want to help other people through and i
struggled the most as an entrepreneur
just trying to get my business off the
ground quitting on my business partner
um when i was uh 19 and really i'm just
making content for 19 year old evan and
i'm a visual guy so i'd much rather see
it than then read about it or listen to
it and i'm just trying to make content
to help people believe in themselves
more and really making content for all
the nineteen-year-old evans out there
who are struggling to get their business
off the ground
and that's amazing some people call you
like the modern day napoleon hill
because you kind of uh are archiving and
gathering the best wisdom best
information best confidence
principles best business principles
from the great minds of our day what do
you think about that statement when
people refer to you that way
uh it's super humbling that was ed
millett who first called me that one was
at his house and and i said wow that
that's a huge honor he said napoleon
hill was the greatest influence in
personal development and you're the
modern-day napoleon hill like can i use
that you mind if i put that up somewhere
gary had had another quote that was
similar or something around that it's
it's an honor man you know i just wanted
to be able to
i never needed to be the guy in front of
the camera i just wanted to be able to
share some of the lessons that i've
learned along the way and i think both
for for lessons but also inspiration to
say hey if this person has had success
with less resources than you currently
have right now why can't you as well
did he leave am i by myself
we lost we lost
we lost dean who's dean
am i am i dean sean we lost sean okay
it's just me i thought hey totally fine
we're totally good i'll get i thought i
thought i got disconnected like sitting
here by myself
dude it's the billion evan show how's it
going actually i've never been showed on
the podcast you guys are meeting billy
for the first time
let's go sorry you got my crappy camera
but uh i got a better one it's not just
not on it looks good okay well let me
let me dive deeper into the store but
wait for sean to come back
like i was saying i think i think when
you
why do you make content you know and and
this sessions me a lot more about
advanced strategies which i'm really
jazzed for because most of the time i'm
helping the people the very very
beginning stages of their journey get
going but today's session and also the
speech that we're doing at sean's event
coming up in vegas we're gonna go more
advanced strategy so if you've been
around for a while and like how do i get
to the next level i already understand
the basic stuff that's what we're gonna
be going over today as well as that
sean's event and he's back dude i
thought i was the one who got kicked out
i was like this is my end but here we
are we're back
that's right man i love street because
it keeps it going and i literally had
the blue screen of death i was like and
we crashed but i'm fired up man i'm glad
billy was able to jump in and i'm
excited to get into these tips so let's
just kick it off we're talking about
five
advanced
tips that you've learned after getting
546
million views and number one is split
test by impression
bands evan what does that mean
how much do you think people are
actually split testing because i'm i
like geek out and dating over this stuff
but what would you say in people you're
working with who's actually split
testing i'd say people split test zero
and wow okay and how much are you split
testing
um we split test when it comes to like
paid ads all day every day when we when
it comes to landing pages or like maybe
some headlines not but i'd also say this
not even close to as much as we should
when i study someone like dan kennedy or
something i'm riddled with guilt about
uh that and you're probably about to
take that guilt to another level as we
talk about how much we should be split
testing on youtube i look at it more as
opportunity not not guilt or shame just
ways to grow and improve uh we've done i
don't know 15 000 split tests now across
our channels with titles and thumbnails
i think it's for anybody who has content
up it's the single biggest leverage
point for your business we're often so
stressed out about the next launch where
if you look at where your views are
coming from it's mostly catalog content
and there's a huge huge huge opportunity
to split test old thumbnails and titles
uh
youtube did a case study on us two years
ago doing it and we had some videos get
like 15 000 time
improvement just by changing the
thumbnail and so you've done all the
work to create the video as long as the
content is still evergreen it's still
gonna be valuable in a year two years
etc
just changing the title thumbnail can
have a massive impact
some people who do split tests do it
based like just after launch like oh my
video didn't get enough views in the
first hour so let me split test that
that's not what i'm talking about it's
more the ongoing if you want to have
long-term sustained growth suggested
becomes the number one place where your
traffic should be coming from and split
testing a thousand thumbnails can have
just an insane improvement on your
results when people ask me well what's a
good split what's a good uh
click-through rate well it depends right
it depends on how many impressions the
videos are get so
uh we split tests by impression bands so
we've developed our own tool that looks
at looks at the channel
looks at uh for example hundred thousand
five hundred thousand impressions and
then five hundred thousand two million
impressions and a million impressions of
five million impressions and see what
the videos are in those ranges and then
every video that is under the halfway
mark gets split test so your number one
video in your channel should have most
likely the lowest click-through rate on
the on the channel
why because it's being recommended to a
brand new audience right so you would
expect the click-through rate to be low
the number one video on my channel has a
two percent click-through rate
which you might say well that sucks no
it's awesome because it's being
recommended to brand new people who've
never heard of me before where if you
get a double-digit click-through rate
i'm actually worried for you because
it's likely only going to your current
subscribers and people know you and it's
not getting out to enough new people so
the biggest opportunity for existing
channels bar none is to look at your
existing videos go past 90 days not like
some old video that nobody cares about
anymore existing videos past 90 days
what's getting you impressions it means
youtube is trying to promote you and
then look at the click-through rate and
see which ones are the lowest there
might be a difference from one percent
up to the five percent seven percent
eight percent difference if you can
boost some of those videos just by
tweaking the thumbnails and titles it
can have a dramatic impact on the
channel and your growth
that's incredibly deep tip and i'm
excited that we got five of these but uh
let me break this down and go a little
bit deeper of how we might be able to do
this so here's the video that came out
in october 29 uh 2021 and if we go into
our analytics here
um we could maybe check out would you
recommend i go like the last
seven days
are you comfortable sharing like
everything yep all right so go back to
your analytics don't look at your mo
don't look at the um
don't look at this one video and don't
look at past 24 hours go analytics okay
see more
uh advanced mode oh sure i usually do
see more oh see more right here okay
yeah
and then go 90 days
90 days and then sort by impressions on
the right
sort by impressions right uh this guy
right here yeah yeah
okay so these are the videos that
youtube is trying to promote on sean's
channel right now and what we want to do
is find similar videos so look at that
one so
how to get your first thousand
subscribers on youtube five tips that
got 3 million 3.3 million impressions
the one underneath it got 3.1 million
impressions right basically the same
right close enough but look at the look
at the click-through rate on the right
2.5 versus 4.4
yep
so we need to fix that title thumbnail
combination
so actually do some split testing on
this title thumbnail yeah now this is
this video is two years old right this
is just over two years old it's still
sean's number two video on the channel
right now
and so by tweaking that thumbnail if we
can get that
to 4.4 click-through rate
now we're not only almost doubling the
traffic to that video but youtube's
going to start recommending our video a
lot more because we're getting a higher
click-through rate on it so this video
and look i mean it's also for revenue
numbers like this video is pulled in
five thousand dollars already for the
channel that could be fifteen thousand
dollars
right yep that's two years old just by
tweaking the thumbnail title so what
would you um so then the split test the
two variables that we can try is title
and thumbnail are you going to do one at
a time and then how long would you wait
to see the impressions change 24 hours
36 hours yeah thumbnails about 70
percent
uh titles about 30 of the decisions for
people to click we found uh you don't
test based off a time period because
that doesn't tell you anything you need
statistical significance
so
we use our own tool that we've developed
internally that that um
just
allows us to do tests at scale that we
might open up to our friends at some
point um but the the best one apart from
that is tubebuddy i know if we talk
about tools or if you're connected or
affiliated or not but um
what it does is reset the thumbnail
every day at 12 midnight pacific
and how long should you run it for
until you get enough statistical data
statistical significance uh so that for
a video like that you should get that
pretty quickly you should get that in a
couple days for a smaller video uh it
might take longer time because you need
more impressions on it
yeah and grant asks was title or
thumbnail seventy percent thumbnail
seventy percent uh according to evan and
then titles thirty percent in terms of
the two things you can tweak
and
you've got a tool but what would be
like if we didn't use the tool for the
situation we're in and i don't even want
to compare it to think media because we
have a lot of content but would you
apply like the 80 20 rule to this would
you mainly optimize the top 20 videos
here because that's we're going to be
our biggest impact is or would you
actually want to work
even down at at the other end of the
spectrum like how would you focus your
energy if we did a whole split testing
campaign
yeah so the lowest hanging fruit are
going to be the ones at the top and what
we're looking for is videos that like
this is saying the impressions means for
everybody watching youtube is trying to
show people this video
so when you see a million impressions of
the past 90 days that means sean's video
youtube is trying to show it a million
times with different people and x
percent two percent clicked on it versus
four percent clicked on it so that's
your lowest hanging fruit right the
instead of trying to get youtube to
promote the video more
they're already trying to promote it and
you're not getting the clicks and this
is not a subjective like thought sean i
think your thumbnail sucks your face
shouldn't be on right this is like the
data is actually telling you there is
something wrong with the thumbnail title
combination because for your channel in
the same impression band category this
video is not getting the clicks it
should compared to that other one
so you definitely start at the top i
wouldn't try to do it manually that's
just way too much headache tubebuddy
that feature costs like 49 bucks a month
so i would honestly just do it with
tubebuddy and always pick statistical
significance because i think their
default is like 10 days or something
which doesn't tell you anything you can
get results in three day four days you
can get it in 90 days just depends on
how much day you get coming in
man that is a crazy tip right there by
the way smash like and and share this
out because i don't even like we have
four more of these that's some pretty
ninja kiki uh advanced youtube strategy
um and uh we're gonna be getting into
some more tips in just a second um smash
the like button and let me know what is
your best performing video drop that in
the comments uh to let me know what that
is and today's episode by the way before
we get into tip number two is brought to
you by grow with video live this is the
grow with video live
show
and uh i'm super fired up evan is one of
our speakers if you're loving the stuff
he's sharing we have an incredible
lineup of speakers in fact just check
out this video this thing is your
gateway to get out of the thing that you
complain about but people would rather
complain about how it is than put in the
work we need to start understanding how
big this opportunity is because for
everybody in this room he will sit back
in 20 30 years and regret if you didn't
execute in this era it has never been a
better time in the human race ever to
actually just go all in on you
regardless of what you're trying to
accomplish you've got to tell the world
about it this is now the world if you're
not betting on this you're finished
[Music]
this is your golden era right now
there's never been a better time to beat
you
this is the greatest golden era of not
only business but life
i desperately want you to win
but this is on you
[Music]
at the time ago and live growth video
live is just 13 days away and um because
you are part of the grow with video live
show use code gwvlshow
growthvideolive.com to get a discounted
ticket prices are going up may 13th
that's 48 hours
from now and so save an additional five
percent off the lowest ticket prices
right now we actually only have 35
tickets left which is pretty cool so
definitely don't wait um we have uh
virtual tickets though we're not going
to run out of those and so if you can't
make it to las vegas uh definitely
grab a virtual ticket and join us from
anywhere in the world we have a whole
half of the think media team that'll be
engaging with you answering questions
and the virtual experience is going to
be amazing growthvideolive.com is where
all the details are and uh evan
carmichael is one of our speakers
how excited are you for it dude i'm
super fired up i mean it's it's turned
into
more than i could have ever imagined
when gary vaynerchuk originally
confirmed that was kind of like the
genesis of going this big but then to
get alex hermosie and layla hermosie
coming out uh to get you coming out um
you know the the gathering of speakers
i've never quite seen a lineup like it
and you know of course our friend uh
daryl and mr beast do do vid summit but
i'm kind of excited you could see we're
going heavy more the entrepreneur angle
with like aaron on demand patrick that
david
yourself you know really more the
business minded or rather um you know
author speaker coach expert angle
leveraging video and uh i'm just super
pumped how about you i mean you're
coming out from toronto to las vegas in
the united states as soon as
i think you reached out and then your
team kind of followed up and i saw like
i'm in i don't even know what the date
it is i'm in i want to support i mean
we've been talking about your events for
a while and they they were always kind
of close and just just you and team and
now you're opening it up it's just guys
sean if you don't know sean sean
is not just one of the hardest working
guys in youtube industry but he actually
like very much deeply cares about seeing
people win on the platform so there's a
lot of events where they just take your
money and run and it's not the greatest
experience um this is not gonna be it
because if sean's involved is gonna be
great so i'm excited vegas
let's go baby let's go baby i appreciate
your kind words evan i'm excited we
shared tip number one which was split
test by impression bands if you're just
joining live you got to rewatch that
whole section but tip number two is aim
for 70 percent ar
at one minute what's ar and what does
this mean
so ar stands for audience retention and
specifically absolute audience retention
so on every video this is
if you don't like data or you find
youtube studio kind of overwhelming this
is probably the most important thing
that you need to pay attention to is
where are people leaving your video so
youtube for every video will show you
second by second where people are
falling off and most people where they
fall off as in the beginning most people
crater right at the beginning and so
what we aim for and what we've seen is
hey if you can hit 70 at one minute
meaning 70 of the people who are
starting the video are still there one
minute later your video has a really
really good chance of taking off where
the danger a lot of people fall into is
the beginning kind of sucks
and even if you've spent a lot of work
making this really long video and it's
awesome you're really proud of it if the
beginning doesn't hook people in
they will not watch and youtube will not
recommend it people do have an attention
span to learn so if it's good content
they will watch but they're making that
decision really quickly remember you're
not making videos for your current
subscribers you're making videos for
people who don't know who you are yet so
even even with me we've got three and a
half million subscribers or something 83
of my audience is non-subscribers that's
good that means you're growing so for a
lot of people watching my content it's
the very first time they're gonna see me
so if you start a video with something
like hey guys welcome back it's me evan
wow i'm so excited to be here happy
thursday tuesday monday right
welcome back i don't know who you are
what am i being welcomed back to and so
you have to have a hook and there's
different techniques you can use
depending on the content format that
you're doing but that first minute
really really really really really
matters if you can keep them for the
minute chances are the watch for the
rest of the video you'll be the slow
decline but pay attention that first
minute aim for 70 if you can do that
your videos will blow
up man powerful tip and we're going to
break down a video that is not 70
percent here but here's our uh one of
omar's best camera videos and we're
seeing our audience retention we use
chapters and so the peaks are people
skipping through the video using the
chapters i'm curious your opinion on
that in just a second but you can use
this to say relative audience retention
is that what you were recommending to
when you're talking about uh obviously
it's only 30 average percentage viewed
but um this this center line is the
average of
videos this length on the platform
correct and so actually near 10 minutes
this is above average but then at the
end it definitely dips uh evan what are
some of your thoughts here so one we
don't look at relative um
we also don't care about percentage view
because it'll depend on how long the
video is we also don't use chapters for
this very reason is that you see people
just skipping forward around and
actually saw that chapters uh reduce the
performance of a video and didn't help
gain search traffic which was part of
the theory of it um but what you just
looked at was uh if you go back to that
last screen where it showed you relative
to your own channel
relative to your own channel yeah so
yeah so that's fine yeah click on that
video so this is what you guys can do
any video this is free you don't pay for
anything it's baked in the studio you
can see there so that that's what we
obsess over here is that that great oh
the great the gray bar the typical
typical for our channel is the gray here
exactly and so we want to outperform
that right and so
this start is not great and this again
is not subjective it's not hey omar wow
i think you suck right that's not that's
not it at all the audience is telling us
that relative to our other videos this
is not a great intro and so
that you can't fix the beautiful thing
about uh you know thumbnail title is you
can tweak it the fact that sean's number
two video is a video that's two years
old and now he can change it and tweak
it and get a huge boost is amazing the
other platforms don't like to do that
right like instagram twitter facebook
you're not going back and updating old
stuff because it's irrelevant a week
later nobody cares about you posted a
week ago on instagram but youtube years
later it's the ultimate leverage for you
uh so you can't change those videos but
what you can do is learn from it to be
better for your next videos
so yeah this is great like what happened
here at the start of this video that
allowed us to keep such a high
percentage and this one is outperforming
the typical on our channel which of
course we want to raise up uh as well
but uh
and your goal is to say
say it again we want to 70 retention at
one minute so one minute would be there
we're close 65
yeah and look and if you obsess over now
this video is also a little short it's
five minutes we normally aim for
something longer
um like at least 10 minutes plus but
this is still great and we can learn
from it also the ending sucks this
wasn't part of our official uh tips so
we can throw some bonuses if you want
but that ending there you can see how it
falls off a cliff
yes ending needs to be changed for
future videos yeah yeah yeah and this
one actually there was like an easter
egg which kind of proves that easter
eggs don't really work and uh kyle
anderson put this uh video together and
and it was kind of more like an
experience for almost an in-person
experience which i think is a tip in and
of itself
it's
it's need to be optimized for youtube
you think about what's the youtube
viewer doing yeah and so in terms of
structure the beginning of the video and
again my focus is mostly on thought
leadership education entrepreneurship
it's not as much on like slime channels
or princess dress up or you know other
stuff but in general the beginning of
the video needs to be some kind of
powerful
clip that makes me want to watch it's a
hook just like a title or landing page
you know the headline sub-headline it's
got to be something that can hook me in
and i don't know if you want to dive in
deeper or if you come to vegas we can
dive deeper in the hallway chatting
about it but the the first minute has to
hook me in
the ending
should never be in my view a like
subscribe comment down below i i've
never asked people to subscribe to my
channel i never asked people to like the
video and yet we have three whatever
million subscribers the ending you see
how that falls off at least on that
video that shawn cho that's what most
people do thank you guys so much for
watching i hope to see you soon don't
forget to like subscribe as soon as you
use language that makes it feel like the
video is over people will leave
and where are they leaving maybe there's
somebody else's video or they close
youtube your goal if you want youtube to
recommend you a lot more your goal is to
continue the session so even though it's
the end of the video recording for you
it's just the end of the first quarter
for the person watching the video and we
want them to go binge on more of your
content if you can teach youtube that
when people watch one of your videos
they end up watching five seven eight
they will recommend you a heck of a lot
more so the call to action at the end
needs to be if you like this video go
watch this one here if you like this
interview with evan i've i've talked to
him before as well the link is right
there next to me go go watch it right
there i'll see you there and i will see
you soon not thank you for watching i'll
see you right there you look to it you
point to it and you guide people that go
click on that end card right there um
and then the call to action in the
middle is to get people on your email
list so
you know sean was trying to sell this
event or his youtube secrets round two i
think we're gonna talk about that at
some point if there's a free bonus
chapter there it is free bonus chapter
or get on we need to get people off of
youtube this is why i love sean it's not
just thinking youtube adsense it's like
how do we build a business around this
so how do we get people off of our email
sorry off of a youtube video onto our
email list so then we can give them
value and ultimately sell them the
products and services that we have so
that's where the middle of the video
comes in so in the middle we need a call
to action to a relevant lead magnet that
could be bonus video a pdf a call with
you a free chapter of the book some kind
of lead magnet that's listed in the
description below you put it in the
middle of the video because people will
still continue to watch the rest of the
video it doesn't hurt your youtube
retention most people either don't do it
at all so start doing that or they put
it at the end and people say goodbye so
beginning
first minute is hooks excitement make me
want to watch the video middle is call
to action to a lead magnet so i capture
the email address and then ending no
ending language we're sending them to
the next video point look over there and
card keep this keep the session going
we're dropping a master class today evan
is bringing the fire and we're keeping
it moving we had uh tip number one split
test by impression bands tip number two
aim for 70 audience retention at one
minute which you can scroll into your
youtube analytics to that one minute
mark see how you're doing um and really
work on those first 50 sec uh 60 seconds
of content but number three is make
longer videos
drop some mind blown emojis in the
comments one to three hours
do you have any one to three hour videos
on your channel let me know in the
comments evan what are you talking about
and break down why this is so powerful
so many people were thinking short short
short short and shorts my own opinions
on we can dive in if you want to
later on that but
um
if you really want to grow the channel
long term suggest it has to be your
number one traffic source it's the most
consistent most reliable pays you the
most has the highest average
viewer retention on those videos so you
have to be thinking suggested strategy
we have seen i used to just recommend 10
minute plus videos uh we've seen the
highest growth at least in in education
how to entrepreneurship thought
leadership in the one to three hour
category people coming to you to learn
and we've seen it
constantly across a lot of channels
where if you're making a five minute
video
try going 20. just take me deeper you
know that video of sean if it was um
tips to get started on youtube and it's
a 10 minute video cool sean's an expert
take me deeper just make that a 45
minute video or an hour long video even
as an experiment even as a crazy one-off
like evan carmichael said to try this
i would i would experiment with making a
one to three hour video where it's just
repeating yourself a million times but
you're actually giving a lot of value
inside the video
and it may not do as well out of the
gate because suggested doesn't ramp up
right away but look at it 30 day 90 day
later and and i would be shocked if that
wasn't not just the best performing
video for you but also the one that pays
you the most money
so here's the video it's two hours and
five minutes 45
uh
suggested traffic from uh views uh
obviously ad revenue can be great
because you can also do the multiple ad
spots um but uh and then average
percentage or average view duration 20
minutes and 53 seconds which is about
four or five times
the five minute average of youtube
itself so even though that's only a
small percentage of the entire
video really
um what do you think i mean this is a
two-hour video yeah yeah more more i
mean you you've got a lot to teach
people like think about what for
everybody watching and again this
the hat i wear is education thought
leadership
kind of content so if you're a slime
channel maybe it doesn't work as well
although
um i help the reactions channel with the
same thing and say hey take all your
reaction videos and smush them into a
two-hour best of or top 10 of your
reactions instantly becomes the number
one video in the channel most revenue
most subscribers most lead sign ups for
the thing that they're selling as well
um so i would definitely look at mashing
up your old content and and making like
a top ten that's a lot of what i do on
my channel uh but yeah take me deeper
like sean's video there is a great
example i would look at that to be the
norm if you want to learn how to be
successful on youtube where are you
going like you're not going to go to
your library although they might have
youtube secrets edition number two so
maybe but you know you're not talking to
your mom or your guidance counselor your
people are going to to youtube to type
how do i x so that first minute really
matters and that video sean showed i
think it was like 60 something percent
at the first minute so they did a great
job there and then people will just keep
watching
if you have great information to share
if you are an expert at what you're
doing and so do not be afraid to go long
if the content is great how did joe
rogan blow up three to four hour long
podcasts with interesting guests right
so don't be afraid to go long we're
seeing huge growth in the one or three
category and worst case do one test do
one test and then come back
come see me in vegas if you post it
today let me know how it's going or come
back 30 90 days later and see if it's
not the best performing video on your
channel most views most subscribers most
revenue
all right so that tip number three was
make longer content are you going to
take evan's challenge are you going to
make a one-hour video a three-hour video
uh evan when you say also make longer
content though what do you think about
some people are sharing they do live
streams they do five hours watching uh
netflix uh nerf flix tandem event uh a
lot of people doing their longer
podcasts i don't know if this content's
as engaging what is your thought when
when you're saying make longer form
content are you saying really like dial
it in
so yes if it's if it's just if it's
boring five hours content that's not
going to be really great on the repeat
right it's got to be actual good content
that you're sharing
the first minute still really matters
wherever live stream a lot of times the
beginning sucks right hey guys we're
going to get started in a couple minutes
uh how you doing what are you drinking
today put something in the chat like
that's great for community but it sucks
on repeat because i'm not part of the
live experience so if you're going to do
a live stream
also youtube does not promote live
streams after the fact it's great to get
immediate eyeballs but
live streams barely rank in browse and
suggested so the best strategy is to
finish the live stream
have a go unlisted edit the video take
the highlight moments from the live
stream pop them at the beginning as a
hook so it makes me want to watch it
because something crazy is going to come
in this video edit out as much as
possible kind of the boring or dull
moments and if that ends up being a five
hour live stream goes down to a two hour
video cool release that to our video
see how it does i think you have some
good results
all right well we still have two more
tips this is a power packed episode but
we're gonna take a a break to talk about
shorts because you mentioned you see
today i gotta take you there you we
we're pulling at the extremes now
because you've got the one to three hour
videos but you're also saying we could
talk about shorts i see you're posting
them on your channel uh what is your
opinion um when it comes to uh shorts
compared to this long form content
strategy
well in comparison there's no comparison
if you have a choice between long form
and shorts you always go long form
always always always always there's no
case for shorts unless all you care
about is just getting views and
subscribers because those people often
do not convert so when you're
consistently releasing shorts it does a
couple things one um
it doesn't always go to the shorts feed
it'll often go to the browse feed so now
you're pulling from your own brows
against your longer videos to show the
shorts which we do not want we are not
monetizing shorts right the fun cool but
it's nowhere close to if you can get you
know 45 seconds short versus sean's
two-hour video where do we want people
to go not just for monetization but also
for people diving further into your
funnel like if you're spending two hours
with sean on his video i'm much more
likely to buy his book to sign up for
his newsletter to come to the events to
watch other videos then if i watch a 45
second one what has happened to a lot of
shorts channels they can blow up and it
looks great for vanity metrics you can
blow up on on subscribers and blow up on
on views on the channel but they do not
convert to long form videos so they
don't they won't watch the long form
videos on your channel and they don't
convert to email sign ups book sales
programs courses whatever you're you're
trying to sell so if the only thing we
care about is i need to get a million
subscribers as fast as possible shorts
is actually probably your best strategy
but you have no business behind it
there's no money coming in and you're
not selling anything afterwards either
yeah that's a great point i mean in that
you know you think about somebody like a
jake feldman who just took over shorts
like i think he got to 10 million
subscribers really fast but it's eight
second
uh computer renderings kind of tapping
into like fall guys and like the
minecraft audience and whatnot um if
that's the model
brands start wanting to maybe pay
attention to you you gotta ask yourself
how sustainable is it but you just got
to know your business model right evan
you got to know i'm going for wide reach
maybe a younger demo and i'm going to
need brands uh and sponsors to really be
the monetization method the shorts
fund's not going to might do well at
that level of views but nowhere near
compared to even just the proper adsense
and so
what is your thought like if you're
going shorts you got to think about your
business model yes
for sure
for sure i mean most people don't have
one um and the good thing about shorts
is you can repurpose that content like
something that pops on shorts might also
pop on tick tock might also pop on
instagram reels so you can repurpose
which is awesome
uh i just wouldn't have that as your
primary youtube growth strategy
especially if you have long form content
coming up so the recommendation i would
give is
prioritize the long-term content first
and on off days or off weeks if you're
not consistent on the content then you
can post shorts as just having something
there on the channel but if you start
really ramping up your growth from
shorts it's it could have a massive
detrimental effect on your channel and
bringing in the wrong audience well
before we get to tip number four uh
would you be willing to go a little bit
deeper because you're kind of playing a
different game than anybody you're
uploading multiple videos a day but to
me it looks like you're going
long form short long form short so kind
of what's happening here and you know
three days ago it looks like there was a
three hour and 30 minute video and then
two shorts so what are we seeing
i would not recommend what i'm doing
okay i'm testing right like i'm playing
so we do
i mean across all of our channels
20 videos a day probably the main
channel is two videos a day there's
there's um yeah there's a whole bunch of
channels we've got there look at these
channels look at all these evan faces
with the different color uh backgrounds
yeah we've been playing around uh we're
still missing some of the the
uh probably our two biggest russian ones
i'm almost a million subscribers or
spanish ones a million subscribers close
so we gotta be dubbed or
full on dub yeah dub is the way to go if
you're going language it has to be
dubbed captions do not work even uh
style dubbing is fine u.n style means
there you still hear the english behind
but the dubbing is on top versus full
dubbing where like they're trying to
match the lip movements which is a lot
more expensive
um anyway that's a little off topic but
i'm doing this a test
you know i'm doing this a test because
it's my job to figure this out and then
if i'm coming to speak i'm going to come
and share the best advice that i've got
from what's working for me right now i
would not recommend to anybody to
release a long-form video and a short on
the same day especially every day what
i'm trying to figure out with shorts is
is shorts
more like brows
more like notifications more like
suggested like how long does a short
video last what's the lifespan will a
short from a year ago be recommended to
me right now
because if it does then there's a
interesting case study there if it's
more like notifications and it just pops
for a week or two i think you're
actually kneecapping the best part of
youtube which is that your content lives
forever and so there's just i don't have
enough data and i don't know anybody who
has enough data on it yet either so i'm
trying to discover the data
um even at the detriment of my own
channel sometimes you have to take you
know two steps back to learn so you can
go step forward so um we're testing it i
have two channels dedicated just to
shorts and i'm doing a daily short on my
main channel
but i would not recommend it as a
primary content platform only using it
as a supplementary to your long form
beautiful um that's one of the things i
love about you too evan is that you're
you're not uh a theorist you're in the
trenches well you have theories that you
actually test you get real data you're
in the trenches and then you verify them
and you pass along your answers it's one
reason why i'm so excited that you're
speaking at growth video live
and i'm excited we have two more uh
advanced tips today that we're getting
into but if you've been loving this
video definitely smash the like button
and maybe tag or share somebody uh that
needs to see this because evan is
pulling back the curtain behind 500 uh
probably over 600 million if not much
more than that once you add up his over
20 youtube channels evan's one of our
speakers at growth video live which is
coming up in just a couple weeks grow
with videolive.com uh if you love
information like this and really it
comes down to this if you're just ready
to be serious about growing your
personal brand with video like if if
you're just kind of dabbling and it's
kind of a hobby well then this event is
probably not for you but if you're like
i i want to get in the room i want to be
able to talk to evan in the hallways i
want to be able to connect with people
that are ambitious that are focused on
the best practices uh you can see who
the speakers are we got gary vaynerchuk
evan carmichael alex hermosie
heather taurus omar alticore uh
growthvideolive.com
and you can get five percent off because
you're part of the grow with video live
show well evan
i want to talk about a very
underutilized youtube feature
and that is number four youtube
stories so actually simplify it for us
because i think a lot of people are
asleep to this feature
um but one of the things that inspires
me is that you use well you you execute
so well you you execute uh incredibly
well on this feature you do some native
stuff there some repurposing what is
youtube stories and what kind of results
have you seen with it
so youtube stories uh and shout out to
sean's book again it's there's there's a
page or two on there where you can learn
about it uh it's it's like snap you know
snapchat started instagram took it
instagram stories became the the big
thing uh and then youtube copied it so
youtube has youtube stories it's
basically the same thing as uh instagram
stories and the cool things that you can
add in
one automatically people can subscribe
to your channel from your store so that
could be a cool way to build um some
more traction attention two your stories
last for seven days so unlike the other
places where they expire in 24 hours a
youtube story lasts for seven days and
maybe the coolest thing of all is you
can put in video links to your own
videos i think there's a limit on what
you can do on your own videos but also
to other videos you can you can link
them up so that people can one click go
from
watching your story to click and then
onto your video
and i don't know that it's worth having
a giant youtube story strategy the way
that i lump it in is mostly if we're
promoting the video that'll be a youtube
story only thing and for the most part
what i do day to day so if you go to my
store today you'll probably see me in
the car saying hey it's it oh we're
going to pull it up there yeah there i
am walking on the street i don't know
what i'm talking about
sharing some kind of message
it doesn't have to be fancy guys it's
like me you know in my office walking on
the street in in some chair you know
it's nice mobile only we can't we can
pull shorts up on desktop we can't even
pull up stories on desktop and so at the
subscriber button there you can see your
face with the red dot on it and uh do
you know the subscriber limit before
you're able to create stories
i don't know i'll look it up
show that thing you just had it you go
back to the story
oh
that that's what so that's a video yeah
yeah so that so that's a video on one of
my channels that you can click and go
watch it
there's there's there's the money
action that people are able to take you
can also link to other channels so
sometimes we link from think media to
think media podcast or vice versa
um you could you could shout other
people out as well but if you have more
than one channel you can use it to cross
promote
yeah and so that's that's it's not just
um brain and just awareness or just
sharing your life but you can actually
link up your videos for people to go and
click on it which is really cool got me
excited by it
apart from that though i would say it's
great to have a
it's great to have just think about you
just be on youtube like you're a content
creator we're trying to build our brand
we're trying to build our business we
need a long-form
content strategy and that's youtube and
it should be and that's going to be your
your number one strategy should be for
2022 2023 and beyond at least as far as
i can think at 2030 who knows what
happens but you need a long-form content
strategy you then need a short form
vertical strategy and that's going to be
youtube short sorry um uh
your youtube yeah youtube shorts
instagram reels tiktok and you can post
the same
thing to multiple platforms and then you
also need some kind of story
content and then that you can post to
snapchat you can post to tick tock
stories tick tock stories is now a thing
you can post instagram stories you can
post to youtube stories and so what i'll
normally do is i'll take out my phone
and in the morning i'll have some kind
of message and sometimes it's once a day
sometimes just multiple times a day
depending on what i'm doing and i'll
film a message um up to 45 seconds
because that's the twitter limit for
video
and then i'll post it to all the
platforms and having that content
strategy then you can apply to all the
platforms like how do i be everywhere
well that's how you be everywhere
without having to create unique content
on every platform
youtube stories is an underutilized
feature and plus evan just really broke
down we have our story
strategy our short form strategy our
long form strategy and you know this
might feel a little bit overwhelming and
it might feel like a lot but evan's been
doing this for years he's built up a
team around it he's built up systems
he's built up his own confidence his own
ability to just grab his phone get on
camera and so wherever you are the key
move is to start start before you're
ready punch fear in the face punch
perfectionism in the face and press
record and then of course get better as
you go so just think about how can i
maybe do you have a little bit of margin
do you want to try something new have
you hit 10 000 subscribers which is how
many subscribers you need before stories
and if you haven't yet no big deal you
can tap into long form and shorts and
and and and if you want more help with
that that's really our heart behind um
our upcoming event as well and so we
have a fifth tip from you
uh i don't want to take evan too long
but he's got too much wisdom so we'll
see where we go we're going to talk
about some deeper stuff about really
building your business promoting your
channel off platform um but
uh if you haven't heard about growth
video live we actually have limited
tickets remaining evan's one of our
speakers check out this video and we'll
be right back do you want to get in the
room with experts like gary vaynerchuk
patrick vette david vanessa lau pat
flynn chalene johnson and more and would
you like to meet hundreds of other
creative entrepreneurs just like you
well then do not miss the chance to get
around creators and business influencers
at growth video live 2022 conference you
can actually lock in your limited
discounted tickets at
growethvideolive.com or you can click
the link in this post or in the
description now if you want to learn the
best new strategies for getting views on
youtube and the most proven and
profitable ways to grow online then do
not miss this life-changing event you
can join us in person in las vegas or
virtually from around the world secure
your ticket at growthvideolive.com and
take the fast track to dominating the
next decade not just with youtube but
with video go to growthvideolive.com or
click the link in this poster in the
description to secure your limited time
discounted ticket
that's right and not only is uh early
bird going on for about 48 more hours
depending on when you're watching this
but you can save an extra five percent
by using the discount code
gwvlshow
growwithvideolive.com and so check it
out if you have any questions go ahead
and post those in the chat or the
comments if you have any questions for
evan we may be able to do a lightning
round but we have one more tip to share
with you um and the fifth tip is kind of
going to be a can of worms
just before that can i share a story i
think will be helpful for grow with
video if you go can you load up my
homepage just evan carmichael.com i want
to share something um now the focus of
this has been at more advanced
strategies because we're geeking out
over dead and everything else but i love
helping people at the beginning of their
journey as well and i'm is this your
homepage yeah scroll down and you'll see
a youtube stats update don't worry about
all this stuff you can read this guys if
you want later but uh here here yeah
there that's my growth
and we need to update that for 2022 but
this is how long
it's rough guys it's rough living out
here first year i had 25 subs and then
107 and then 344 like it took a long
time five years in i only have 2 000
subscribers so a lot of you guys here
already in the chat are already ahead of
where i was probably after my fifth year
and so even though the main theme here
is more advanced strategies and in the
theme when i'm speaking with more
advanced stuff i i love helping the
beginners i my heart is still here
hopefully this serves in some kind of
inspiration for you guys as well to just
keep making keep sharing keep growing
keep learning and if you're thinking
about grow with video one of the best
things you can do is just be around
people
who are ahead of you and who are doing
things and where there's excitement
because if you're the only person doing
youtube in your family or your circle
that can be kind of alone and and uh
hard to keep going but when you're
around other people who are doing big
things it can be inspiring so hopefully
in all of the advice we're given here i
hope you don't the the goals to not make
you feel overwhelmed
if you take one thing and you get
inspiration from it and you keep going
and taking action that could that could
be the thing that makes you potentially
the next speaker go with video you know
next year the year after and get your
big breakthrough so if you're coming to
the event come find me in the hallway my
favorite thing is helping people
one-on-one being introverted and shy i
know it doesn't come across but i am i
probably won't say hi to anybody when
i'm there so come find me bring your
channel bring your laptop let's let's
dissect some of the stats on your
channel and i'm super looking forward to
meeting you
yes and uh evan's not kidding i'm
grateful for his heart to serve as well
i mean in fact serve you got a book uh
called serve is that true
built to serve
built to serve yeah that's the book so
this is one of the bonus strategies i
guess tip number five for how you can
use youtube videos our platform so on
amazon you can also link up your videos
so if you look at my author profiles
we've you know got some books out but
you can also link up your
um latest videos and shorts uh on on the
channel as well so
leverage guys right like it takes so
much work to make a video that the more
we can we can use that content and place
it on other platforms the better um
another great strategy we've already
talked about like using your shorts as
reels and using your stories on
instagram stories and tick tock stories
and snapchat so you're everywhere um
also when if you look at your audience
retention curve and you ever see a spike
you can cut that to be your short you
can cut that to be your tweet you can
cut that to be your instagram video
right so in every single yeah like most
of my all of these things that i'm
posting we have some custom animations
and cartoons but for the most part these
are our youtube videos
and i don't know what are we at tik tok
sean what are how many what are we at
oh that's instagram so it was 260 on
instagram and and tick tock is like 500
something a thousand um but it's it's
basically just our youtube content and
what we do is we look at the audience
retention curve where it shows what
people liked and what they didn't like
and we take those highlight moments yeah
so like 500 000
followers 11 million likes on on tick
tock these are all just youtube videos
that we're cutting up
um so you look at those highlight
moments and now you have content for
every platform and the data shows you on
youtube what's performing really well
based off your items retention curve cut
those and now it gives you content to be
everywhere so for the people who are
struggling like how do we everywhere
this is crazy i can't keep up with
everything
you don't have to you just have to make
long youtube content and then you can
use that to cut up to be on all the
other platforms
yeah and uh to to i think show that
specifically uh this is this is a good
example chris doe also shared this on
the think media podcast
um about where they were finding shorts
and reels and tick tocks you look at
these spikes
and this spike it means right evan that
someone's either rewinding this moment
right
most likely is that what the spike would
tell you and that that could be a moment
we say okay what did we share here
yeah so like yeah we see a spike at the
beginning of your video and that's most
likely people are fast-forwarding
like they're fascinating maybe there's
something about
the pandemic and i don't and and it's
still a spike even whatever and then
there's some later but uh yeah what's
the spike mean yeah most likely people
are rewinding to watch that part again
like what did he say
and so even if it's flat if it's if the
curve is flat that means nobody left so
whatever you said there was really good
right it held people's attention but if
you ever see a spike up that means
people most likely rewound to watch that
part again which means it's really
really really good
you don't always have spikes in every
video so at least looking for the flat
parts which means nobody left you held
their attention those could be great
clips and then cut up yeah look at this
one
this is
yeah and this one was also what i did
was i stitched some videos together to
make it longer form
these are some editing tips in here and
we did this exact strategy and we've
tested it where it also it was give us
two insights one insight was okay can we
clip this part and turn it into a short
or a tick tock or a reel and then the
other insight was actually should i
double down on this topic one of the
things i learned here was i started to
explain bit rates and export settings
and i was like why would anyone care
about that but that moment in the video
i was like oh
like someone clearly was those watching
it were rewinding and i was like that
also could be something i should double
that double down on making to its own
video when i was just responding to one
question off the cuff for sure have you
looked at the new research tool as well
uh i've spent a little bit time let's
see is it on this channel i think it
only might be on our other channel is it
rolled out to everybody yet not yet
here we go
okay so research so this is cool so this
if you're looking at how do i find nice
topics for to make videos on
um
if you go research and then click on
what shawn did your viewer searches it's
the middle one you can scroll down and
it gives you some suggestions it looks
like someone's been using it you already
bookmarked video editing as one these
are some ideas that sean could make for
his channel
and based off of what his what his
audience people like his audience are
looking for so if you're ever struggling
i know at the beginning it was like what
videos do i make how do i find good
topics the three ways that are easy to
find video topics and we didn't add this
on you know in our pre-chat so like
bonus bonus bonus tip
one is to use a research
uh tool here with this is brand new and
so you can look at it especially yeah
especially you have a content gap on
there so the second one has a content
gap or you get more here too basically
mean like there's a lot of search
um but but there's not a lot of supply
now this may not fit sean right annoying
sounds
yeah and the reason that's there is
because we did it was actually normal
for 10 hours of annoying sounds
videos that'd be that'd be a crazy
upload but probably do really well um
i'm but it also i've even thought evan
you know it was
we do help people with editing so nolan
supplied just some
funny sounds and some meme sounds
they're heavily searched based videos
but the truth is i recognize they're
attracting subscribers that are
definitely not our if you will
subscribers yeah so i just like shorts
would too like you bring in the wrong
people sometimes so and that's fine you
make a judgment call but yeah three
quick ways to find good video ideas one
is using that research tab the second is
if you look at the audience tab so
there's a uh you have to have a little
bit of data before you really get some
good info from it but at the top it says
audience and then scroll down on the
right it'll show you the channels that
they watch but here other
videos exactly so and and this is
updated constantly every every it's like
every day you'll find new stuff in here
based off the last seven days and you
can see which ones fit you know why i
left hong kong may not be a good fit for
sean but some of the other ones might
and just worth looking at uh like
youtube raids are here you know do we
talk about youtube grades maybe new
trend um so this is worth looking
through as you get data and then the
third one is vid iq will also give you
uh um as part of their plug-in i don't
know if we talk about it iq but vidiq
gives you a plugin where it can
recommend some video topics for you as
well so if you're struggling to like
what videos do i make how do i how do i
stay consistent on my content those are
three easy ways to get some good ideas
yeah vidiq like the daily ideas tool
yeah so they have a list of uh i think
it's 50 that you can look at and
bookmark and see it as a giant list um
yeah there you go i gotta log into my
right account one second okay but yeah
daily ideas i guess this one gives you
this is free because i'm logged into the
wrong account here but it gives you
three if you just get vidiq installed at
the free level but if you got boost or
pro they start giving you refreshed
every id every day you can save ones
that you want to make later
and uh pretty cool daily ideas tool
yeah and so if you're on the upgraded
one you get i think it's 50 a day or
maybe more i mean we don't need that
many but even at my channel we look at
we look at that tool vidiq we look at
research and we look at related audience
every day because there'll be some cool
topics in there that you never thought
of but you could totally do that video
and sometimes it helps relieve the
burden of having to brainstorm new ideas
for your channel when you get that list
of topics to create yeah and then and
that's kind of got a prediction of high
view predict
viewership high very high high or medium
and then you can kind of help educate
the tool by exiting them out or
harding them and adding them to your
to-do list really great power tips uh i
wanted to circle back and we're really
just going to land the plane here in a
second we may answer a question or two
but with off platform strategies in
celebration of uh youtube secrets second
edition is out by the way friends let's
go um and so benji and i updated the
book and uh the kindle's not quite
updated yet but the physical book is
shipping i've always obviously got one
of my hands here uh the audiobook is
fully re-recorded that's out on audible
and um
there's 80 new pages every page the
stats the data have been rewritten the
new introduction because it's we really
from our data discovered that this next
decade is going to be the best decade on
youtube um it's crazy to see the growth
in the crater economy uh the growth of
youtube consumption and viewership of
course there's opportunity on a lot of
platforms right evan that's why i grow a
video live it's grow with video because
we have people talking about how you can
repurpose your content or be leveraging
tick tock and reels and linkedin video
and facebook video facebook reels and it
goes on and on uh but super excited
about this and uh one of the things that
uh i was inspired by was uh evan already
kind of touched on it but was just this
idea of asking yourself you know what
are your what are your other pro pro uh
products and programs you know what are
your other uh have you written a book
are you planning on writing a book
you're writing an ebook and you know
evan's got his five uh books up here uh
and then also though a page here where
he's even cross-promoting um his youtube
channel and uh connected up is is these
videos that even on his amazon page
these can send traffic and cross-build
authority
over to his youtube channel and so i
think our mutual friend brendan burchard
talks about circular video viralocity or
circular viralocity where you can kind
of just how are you going multi-platform
how are you being omnipresent and how
are you strategically you know serving
whoever it is you want to help with uh
your overall business model thoughts on
that evan and um you know maybe you talk
a little bit about built to serve which
is your great book um as well
well i mean built to serve the ideas you
are built to serve if you're not happy
because you're not serving just how do
you do it and whom do you serve that's
what the book dives into so figuring out
your most important core value your
purpose your passion and then turn into
a business that you can actually
leverage and run with and have you
promoted it though so for somebody else
that maybe wants to write a book launch
a product and whatnot like you've you've
got it of course on amazon but you've
got your channel you've got your social
media uh we don't that's a whole other
topic if we were talking about book
launches or something but uh yeah as far
as what are some of your
uh basic tips
well what
whenever i'm working with somebody who
their goal is not just to be a youtuber
where the business model is adsense then
it's what are you trying to sell and
whatever you're trying to sell show me
the process of you doing it so for
example if you want to sell a membership
a package or if you're a coach the best
content you can make is not this this is
direct-to-camera content i love it doing
this this is great this is great for uh
sean dapone's events it's great to be a
speaker but if you're a coach or you
want to sell coaching programs the best
content you can showcase is you coaching
somebody and you'll probably be more fun
to make as well because you actually get
a human in front of you instead of you
just talking to the camera so whether
you want to sell a book a course a
program coaching whatever it is that you
want to sell it's how i start with like
what do you want to sell and then show
me the process of you doing it so if
it's a book show with the process week
by week of you writing the book and
ask answering people's questions you can
pre-sell 100 copies of the book or 500
copies of the book and people get a
25-minute one-on-one with you that
becomes a youtube video as well so it's
like what are we trying to sell and then
let's make content around that to help
us achieve our sales goal
beautiful well we've been talking about
advanced uh tips and uh rapid fire
lightning run evan as we're landing
plane uh known as description and tags
for shorts do you do you add a
description in tags
uh well tags are zero across everything
so i wouldn't worry about tags for
anything shorts long form we haven't
seen a single impact
also description description the best
use of a description is to guide them to
a lead magnet so like we talked about
earlier in the middle of the video we
want to be linking up we want their
email address get them off of youtube
onto your email in exchange for a bonus
pdf
or bonus video or free chapter of your
book et cetera
that should be the first line in your
description and we still put in
descriptions afterwards but it's very
very little f very little results for it
and tags are zero
um
if a video is blowing up should i wait
to give it time or upload the next
scheduled video irrespective of the last
video for me that depends on how much
browse is an important part of your
um
your your your traffic source for me we
don't we don't focus on it i mean we get
a lot of browse but suggest is number
one and suggest is where i want to play
because people watch longer you get paid
more you grow your channel much more
quickly but also for the long term so we
had a if we had a video blow up next day
we're uploading another video if we had
a video tank next day we're uploading
another video just keep the content
train going as opposed to trying to time
it constantly i think you could just end
up having better results
is it a good strategy to go longer
videos marina is saying
her audience is from shorts videos so
would you recommend she tests longer
videos
uh what are you trying to sell like
what's the ultimate goal for you if
you're if you're saying the thing is all
i care about is i want to get a million
subscribers on my channel as fast as
possible just keep doing shorts cool you
just don't have a business there there's
no real business attached to it yet or
likely anytime soon if you want to be
able to make money from youtube
especially the ad platform and be able
to sell your books and courses and
training programs then long form needs
to be the number one strategy for you
beautiful well uh evan you've spent over
an hour with us we've been through a
crash together i had my blue screen of
death
billy came in and rescued uh us there
you've shared five powerful tips if
you're just joining um definitely watch
the replay and maybe share this out uh
with somebody if you got value today if
you don't mind hitting like as well if
people want to follow you evan where can
they follow you online
i'm evan carmichael most places and uh
if you're coming to vegas come say hi
come find me in the hallway
yes and if you're coming to vegas uh
someone asks is the event two days the
event is two days it's a monday and a
tuesday
growethvideolive.com is where all the
details are there is a third day it's
called our platinum experience which
includes a business mastermind day on
wednesday as well
and if you're a little bit further along
in your business or you really want to
get in the room around
some higher level people it's not
cheap
but it's going to be incredibly powerful
and so all the details are at growth
videolive.com this is the
growth video live show so we want to
hook you up with an extra five percent
off tickets by using the promo code um
so you can certainly take advantage of
that um and if you want to connect uh
with evan he's one of the most generous
uh humble helpful i mean he's dropped
major fire in this video it would take
hours and hours and days to exhaust all
the wisdom that he has and so um not
only is he gonna be speaking at growth
video live but you definitely could have
a chance to meet him take a selfie
uh and more than that bring your laptop
or phone in your analytics so he could
pick a pouch part your channel and help
you grow um even faster we appreciate
you for being a part of the show today
boris glenn thank you so much for
being here
growthvideolive.com is the website and
this is the grow a video live show like
the video if you haven't liked it
subscribe if you're not subscribed and i
can't wait to see you in the next
episode of the growth video live show
this thing is your gateway to get out of
the thing that you complain about but
people would rather complain about how
it is than put in the work we need to
start understanding how big this
opportunity is because for everybody in
this room he will sit back in 20 30
years and regret if you didn't execute
in this era it has never been a better
time in the human race ever to actually
just go all in on you
regardless of what you're trying to
accomplish you've got to tell the world
about it this is now the world you're
not betting on this you're finished
[Music]
this is your golden era right now
there's never been a better time
[Music]
but this is on you